Hallo, guten Abend. Omer Demir ist mein Name. Ich bin hier als Assistenzarzt tätig und möchte das Anamnese-Gespräch mit Ihnen durchführen.
Bevor wir anfangen, benötige ich kurz Ihre persönlichen Daten. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, hallo, guten Abend. Ja, natürlich. Gerne.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Alexander Scherer. Alexander ist der Vorname.
Ok. Könnten Sie mir bitte Ihren Vornamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Alexander ist Anton Ludwig, Emil X, Anton Nordpol, Dora, Emil Richard, Alexander.
Wie Emil und Richard?
Richard, genau. Und Nachname ist Scherer, Siegfried, also Scherer, Emil Richard, Emil Richard. Scherer.
Herr Scherer.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 33 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 23. Februar 1993.
Wie viel ist das?
93.
92.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Scherer?
1,73 Meter.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
72 Kilo.
Vielen Dank für die Angaben. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Herr Dr. Oemer heißen Sie, ich habe einen Freund, der heißt auch Oemer. Ein guter Junge.
Ja, super.
Herr Doktor, ich merke seit einer Woche, dass ich, wenn ich mich belaste, etwas schwer Luft bekomme.
Also das habe ich früher nie gemerkt. Ich mache viel Sport, ich laufe, ich mache Training, ich fahre Fahrrad und so weiter.
Aber seit einer Woche merke ich, wenn ich ein, zwei Stockwerke mit den Treppen steige oder Fahrrad fahre, dann muss ich Pause machen und nach Luft atmen.
Bekommen Sie auch Schmerzen, Brustschmerzen?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich nicht. Es ist nur, ich merke, die Luft fällt mir schwer.
Und ja, da muss ich ein bisschen Pause machen und kann dann wieder weiter, aber das ist etwas unangenehmer, das habe ich vorher noch nie gehabt.
Ja, verstanden. Seit einer Woche haben Sie diese Atemnot. Sind diese Beschwerden plötzlich oder eher langsam aufgetreten?
Also plötzlich in dem Sinne, dass ich es gemerkt habe. Es war am Anfang etwas weniger, jetzt ist es aber mehr geworden.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Auslöser für diese Beschwerden bemerkt? Zum Beispiel irgendwelche eine infektuelle Erkältung oder?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt. Also ich war nicht erkältet. Ich kann mir jetzt nichts vorstellen, was es ist.
Okay. Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, was diese Beschwerden versteht außer körperlicher Belastung? Zum Beispiel beim Liegen oder in der Nacht?
Nein, nein. Also es ist wirklich nur bei Belastung, wie Sie sagen.
Okay. Haben Sie ein enger Gefühl?
Sie meinen auf der Brust?
Ja, genau.
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Hören Sie, dass Ihr Herz nicht regelmäßig schlägt oder stolpert?
Nee, ich habe mich auch schon kontrolliert. Also mein Puls ist an sich regelmäßig. Ich habe jetzt keine Aufwendigkeiten bemerkt.
Ist Ihnen etwas aufgefallen, was diese Beschwerden lindert?
Ja, Pause machen. Also wenn ich aufhören würde, oder wenn ich mich hinsetze ein paar Minuten, dann wird es wieder besser.
Haben Sie schon etwas dagegen bekommen als Medikament?
Nein, nein. Also es ist etwas unangenehm, aber schlimm war es bisher nicht.
Aber ich habe nichts eingenommen. Deswegen bin ich jetzt bei Ihnen.
Ja, verstanden.
Weil ich so lange Besorge habe.
Haben Sie gesagt, dass diese Beschwerden erstmals auftreten?
Das habe ich noch nie gesagt.
Okay.
Haben Sie neben dieser Atemnot andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Husten?
Nein, Husten habe ich nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie Schwellung in den Beinen?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Nein, habe ich nicht.
Fühlen Sie sich schwach oder müde?
Ich kann gut schlafen. Ich kann mich so ganz normal, sage ich mal wie immer, belasten. Aber nein, ist mir nichts Besonderes aufgefallen. Nein.
Okay. Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein.
Okay. Mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, bisher auch nicht. Nein. Also an sich fühle ich mich recht gut. Es ist halt nur bei Belastung, wie gesagt.
Verstanden. Haben Sie keine Husten? Okay. Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen außer Atemnot nichts aufgefallen? Haben Sie keine anderen Beschwerden?
Nein. Ich gehe zur Arbeit. Ich kann ganz normal essen und trinken. Ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Nein.
Alles klar. Wie ist Ihr Appetit derzeit, Herr Scherer?
Ganz gut. Also ich habe da keine Probleme.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder beim Stuhlgang?
Nein. Nein. Klappt alles ganz gut.
Ist Ihr Schlaf? Schlafen Sie gut? Oder haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder Durchschlafen?
Nein. Schlafen klappt gut. Eigentlich ganz gut, ja.
Können Sie flach liegen?
Ja.
Ohne Atemnot zu bekommen?
Nein. Ich kann flach hinlegen, ja.
Müssen Sie mehrere Kissen benutzen zum Schlafen?
Nein. Bisher noch nicht. Also noch kann ich mich relativ gut flach hinlegen, ja.
Okay. Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit merklich verändert? Haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Nein. Also ich bin immer so 71, 72 Kilo gewesen, ja.
Ja, verstanden.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Vorerkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel erhöhte Blutdruck, Blutzuckerkrankheit oder sowas?
Nein. Hab ich glücklicherweise auch nicht. Aber mein Vater hat Diabetes.
Der nimmt seit fünf Jahren Medikamente. Und meine Mutter hat hohen Blutdruck.
Seit fünf Jahren, haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, genau. Mein Vater nimmt seit fünf Jahren Medikamente.
Okay. Ihre Mutter hat auch Blutdruck?
Ja, ja auch. Jetzt hat sie, glaube ich, schon seit über 20 Jahren.
Okay. Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Eigentlich nicht. Nur wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, nehme ich mal ein bisschen Ibuprofen.
Was für Schmerzen bekommen Sie manchmal?
Ich mache ja sehr viel Sport. Ich mache sehr viel Sport. Und wenn ich mich da mal verletze, dann nehme ich gerne mal eine Ibuprofen.
Wurde bei Ihnen schon mal eine Operation durchgeführt?
Nein. Bisher glücklicherweise alles gesund.
Ja, das freut mich sehr.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt, Herr Schörer?
Ja, ich habe also ein bisschen Pollenallergie und Milben und Hausstaub.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Also gerade jetzt zum Beispiel die Pollenallergie. Mir läuft die Nase, die Augen tränen. Abends bekomme ich geschwollene Augen.
Milben und Hausstauballergie?
Ja, da bekomme ich manchmal auch so ein bisschen laufende Nase.
Nur laufende Nase?
Ja.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten zum Beispiel gegen bestimmte Nahrungsmittel?
Nein, das bin ich auch nicht.
Ich möchte jetzt über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten etwas fragen, Herr Schörer. Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Eigentlich schon. Sehr selten. Eigentlich nicht.
Dann nehme ich an, dass Sie keine Drogen konsumieren, oder?
Nein, also Drogen habe ich jetzt auch nicht.
Wie alt ist Ihr Vater?
Er ist ca. 58 Jahre alt.
Er leidet an Zuckerkrankheit. Seit fünf Jahren haben Sie gerade erzählt. Hat er noch weitere Erkrankungen? Wissen Sie?
Also er ist auch sehr gesund und sehr sportlich. Soweit ich weiß, hat er keine weiteren Erkrankungen mehr.
Welcher Typ von Zuckerkrankheit hat er? Wissen Sie?
Das weiß ich nicht. Wie viele Typen gibt es denn da an Zuckerkrankungen? Ich dachte das nicht.
Die berühmten Typen sind der erste und der zweite Typ.
Ach so, ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Ist es jetzt schlimm oder ist es wichtig, jetzt zu wissen, welchen Typ Diabetes mein Vater hat?
Ja, manche Krankheiten können ärblich sein. Deswegen...
Sie meinen, ich kann das auch bekommen oder was?
Ich meinte das nicht. Nur möchte ich wissen, welcher Typ Ihr Vater hat.
Ist das gefährlich jetzt für mich? Hab ich jetzt auch Diabetes, Herr Doktor?
Nein, diese Fragen sind Routinefragen.
Wir machen mir ein bisschen Angst, Herr Doktor. Deswegen fragen...
Nein, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Diese sind Routinefragen.
Ach so, okay.
Wie alt ist Ihre Mutter?
Sie ist 56.
Hat sie auch noch außer Bluthochdruck andere Vorerkrankungen?
Die hat einige Sachen, aber alles weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, ja, dir geht es gut. Dir geht es besser als ich, ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Scherer?
Nein, aber ich lebe in einer festen Beziehung.
Meine Partnerin bzw. meine Freundin. Wir sind seit 10 Jahren zusammen, aber verheiratet sind wir noch nicht.
Verstanden. Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Herr Scherer?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Was unterrichten Sie?
Ich unterrichte Englisch und Sport.
Ich habe noch einige Fragen, Herr Scherer.
Ich habe heute viele Fragen gestellt, ach Gott.
Das sind viele Fragen, echt.
Ja, manchmal kann das so passieren.
Ist Ihnen irgendwelche Hautveränderungen aufgefallen?
Nein, nein. Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, wenn ich überlege.
Okay. Jetzt bin ich fertig mit meinen Fragen, Herr Scherer.
Ah, okay.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ich würde gerne wissen, was das jetzt ist. Ist es was Schlimmes oder ist es gar nichts oder bitte ich mir das alles nur ein?
Ich mache mir einfach Fragen, wissen Sie?
Ja, bitte bleiben Sie ruhig, aber leider kann ich Ihnen momentan nicht genauer sagen, was Sie haben.
Wir haben nur unser Anamnesige-Gespräch fertiggestellt.
Zur weiteren Abklärung müssen wir noch weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ah, okay. Ja, das wäre schön.
Erst dann können wir über Ihre Diagnose genauer besprechen.
Okay, okay. Gut. Vielen Dank.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Hab ich eine Frage?
Ja, bitte.
Ist Ihnen Nachschweiß? Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Gute Frage. Nein, habe ich nicht.
Danke.
Darf ich fragen?
Bitte schön.
Was für Sport machen Sie? Treiben Sie? Hatten Sie einen Unfall oder eine Verletzung vor Ihren Beschwerden aufgetreten?
Genau, ich mache sehr viele verschiedene Sportarten.
Ich spiele Fußball, ich fahre Fahrrad, ich jocke, ich schwimme, Fitness.
Vor ca. 10 Tagen hatte ich einen kleinen Unfall beim Fußballspielen.
Ein anderer Spieler hat mir gegen die Vade getreten.
Sehr gute Frage. Diese Frage habe ich gewartet.
Haben Sie einen Traum gehabt? Sehr gut. Eine Frage fehlt aber noch.
Ich habe auch eine Verletzung gefragt, aber Sie haben nichts gesagt.
Ja, also ich habe keine Verletzung.
Nehmen Sie Hormone?
Nein.
Noch eine Frage fehlt.
Haben Sie als Kind Allergie erkrankt?
Ich habe schon gefragt und geantwortet.
Ja, mir nicht.
Ist Ihnen Herzrasen aufgefallen?
Herzrasen gibt es auch nicht.
Wissen Sie, wie es da ist?
Ich habe ein Telefonproblem. Sorry. Nein, Beinschwirrung habe ich keine.
Haben Sie eine Temperaturenfindigkeit? Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, es war im Bereich eine Trauma.
Bitte beschreiben Sie diese Bereich. Gibt es irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten?
Also ich sehe keine Schwellen, keine Auffälligkeiten.
Ich habe keine Schwellen.
Nur ein leichter Schmerz.
Aber es stört mich jetzt nicht.
Ich habe gedacht, das ist einfach nur durch diese Prellung von dem Kollegen.
Ich habe mir jetzt nichts dabei gedacht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig? Nein.
Okay, danke.
Eine Frage fehlt.
Haben Sie Wadenkranke? Nein.
Eine weitere Frage fehlt. Woran müssen wir noch denken?
Reiseanamnese.
Lange Fahrt, Flugzeug, lange Autofahrt.
Waren Sie in der Lesterzeit im Ausland? Ja.
Ich bin vor zwei Wochen aus Australien zurückgekehrt.
15 Stunden Flug.
Okay, jetzt haben wir Labortest gemacht.
Welche Labortest machen Sie, Herr Dr. Masch?
Ich würde...
...großes Blutbildentzündungsparameter...
...Gerindungsparameter...
...de-dimer...
...Nieren- und Leberwerte...
Jawohl.
...werde ich veranlassen.
Was machen Sie noch für eine Untersuchung?
Ich werde natürlich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen...
...einen Röntgen-Torax veranlassen.
Und wenn Röntgen-Torax unauffällig ist...
...werde ich CT-Torax durchführen.
Was machen Sie vorher?
Ganz einfach? EKG.
Ja, EKG. Ja, natürlich.
Sie sehen im EKG ein Sinusrhythmus.
Ich habe akustisch nicht gehört.
Okay.
Puls von 80.
Ein Rechtschenkelblock.
Sie haben De-dimer gemacht.
Troponin-Test ist negativ.
De-dimer sind positiv.
Nierenwerte sind in Ordnung.
Schilddrüsewerte brauchen Sie auch, wenn Sie CT-Torax machen wollen.
Schilddrüse ist auch in Ordnung. TSA ist normal.
Leber, Nieren, Blutbild, alles in Ordnung.
Um eine Embolle auszuschließen, werde ich CT-Angiografie durchführen.
Alles klar.
Jetzt machen wir erst mal die Übergabe.
Und sprechen am Ende vielleicht Diagnose, Verdachtsdiagnose, Differentialdiagnose usw.
Wäre das okay?
Ja, okay, gerne.
Alles klar.
Oder sind noch Fragen?
Kann ich direkt anfangen oder kann ich ein paar Minuten?
Wenn Sie Zeit brauchen, dann gehen wir in diese zwei Minuten und dann können wir uns noch mit den anderen Kollegen unterhalten.
Okay, nur zwei Minuten, okay.
Gibt es vielleicht noch Fragen von anderen Kolleginnen oder Kollegen? Dr. Doblak spricht immer sehr viel.
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Hübner, darf ich fragen?
Wer möchte fragen?
Ich.
Wer ist ich?
Haben Sie Atemnot beim Einatmen oder beim Ausatmen?
Ach gut. Also in Ruhe habe ich keine Atemnot, nur bei Belastung.
Ja, bei Belastung frage ich.
Ja, bei Belastung. Oh, das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Beim Einatmen.
Und ist Ihnen Pfeifen aufgefallen?
Nein, Pfeifen habe ich jetzt nicht.
Danke.
Herr Oberhörst, ich habe Ihnen einmal nachgefragt, Wadenkrämpfe.
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe keine Wadenkrämpfe.
Normalerweise erwarten wir Wadenkrämpfe bei Colmina Emboli häufig oder nicht?
Das muss nicht sein. Nein, Wadenkrämpfe nicht.
Aber das können wir am Ende besprechen, was es sein kann.
Aber so leichte Schmerzen, leichte Schwellung haben wir manchmal, nicht immer.
Und das ist nicht so typisch für Moner Emboli. Keine Vertigo, keine Pusten, keine Hemo-Tier. Was ist das?
Gute Frage. Deswegen sind Sie Ärztin und ich bin der Patient.
Keine Ahnung, wie man das herausfindet. Dr. Oemmer muss das jetzt finden.
Er macht eine gute Suchung.
Ich habe das nicht gut verstanden.
Haben Sie in Wadenbereich leichte Schwellung und Schmerzen oder nichts?
Schwellung habe ich nicht. Ich habe keine Krämpfe, keine Schwellung.
Keine Schmerzen?
Nur minimal, aber das stört mich nicht. Das ist ganz wenig. Deswegen sehe ich das nicht als Schmerz an.
Ja, okay.
Ja, ich bin ein ganz komischer Patient. Was soll ich machen?
Ein sportlicher Mann und Sport. Deswegen vielleicht unspecifisch könnte es sein, oder?
Genau diesen Patienten habe ich vor vier Tagen gehabt.
Oh, ja, 33 Jahre alt und ja, genau. Muss man wie Detektiv sein.
Deswegen macht der Arztberuf so Spaß, man ist ein Detektiv.
So, sind Sie bereit, Dr. Oemmer?
Ja, wir können anfangen.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Abend, sehr geehrte Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo, Herr Dr. Oemmer. Grüß Gott, Servus, guten Abend, wie geht's?
Es geht mir gut und Ihnen?
Dankeschön, danke schön. Sie brauchen nicht sehr geehrt zu sagen.
Es reicht, wenn Sie mich Florian nennen. Wir können uns ja schon duzen. Sie sind jetzt schon so lange dabei.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und würde gerne seinen Fall Ihnen vorstellen.
Jawohl.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Alexander Scherer. Er ist 33 Jahre alt und geboren am 23. Februar 1993.
Er ist 1,73 Meter groß und wiegt zurzeit 72 Kilogramm.
Der 33-jährige Patient Herr Scherer stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seiner Woche bestehender progredienter Belastungsdüstnüfte vor.
Er berichtete, dass er nur ein oder zwei Stockwerke schaffen könne.
Er hatte keinen Auslöser für die Beschwerden.
Vor zehn Tagen gab er an, dass er vor zehn Tagen beim Fußballspielen eine Verletzung gehabt habe.
Im Wadenbereich hatte er leichte Schmerzen.
Wo, auf beiden Seiten?
Wie bitte?
An welcher Wade hatte er Schmerzen?
Welche?
Ich sage einfach nichts.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Schwellungen bemerkt, Herr Doktor? Haben Sie die Wade untersucht?
Nein, er hat keine Schwellung. Die Fragen nach dem Tachikardia, Tussis, Schmerzen, Schmerzen, Nachschweiß wurden verneint.
Interessant.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist auch unaufwendig. Er hat keine Schwellungen. Er nimmt nur Ibuprofen bei Bedarf ein.
Relativ gesünder Jungmann sozusagen, ja?
Ja, genau.
Bei ihm ist bisher keine Operation durchgeführt worden.
Er hat eine Polenallergie, Milbenallergie und Hausstauballergie.
Er hat die erste Allergie durch Rhinokonjunktivität, die zweite und dritte Allergie durch Rhinitis.
Unverträglichkeit hat er nicht. Sein Vater leidet an Diabetes Medikamentus. Welchen Typ? Kenne er nicht.
Er leidet an Diabetes Medikamentus seit fünf Jahren. Seine Mutter leidet seit ungefähr 20 Jahren an arteriöle Hypertonie.
Er hat eine Schwester, die sie gesucht hat. Er ist kein Raucher. Er trinkt sehr selten Alkohol. Er konsumiert keine Drogen.
Er lebt mit seinen Partnern zusammen und hat keine Kinder. Er ist Lehrer von Beruf und er lebt Englisch und Sport.
Bei der Reise an Amnese ist er vor zwei Wochen aus Australien zurückgekehrt.
Der Flugreise habe 15 Stunden gedauert.
Aufgrund der anamnestischen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf eine pulmonäre Embolle.
Was veranlassen Sie für Untersuchungen?
Besonders fokussiere ich mich auf die Auskultation der Lunge und des Herzens.
Ich werde auch Blut abnehmen, um einige Laborwerte zu überprüfen.
Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Gerinnungsparameter, Neurons, Leberwerte, kardiale Enzyme, Troponin E.
Ich werde die Vitalparameter überprüfen und eine EKG schreiben.
Ich werde auch eine Röntgen-Thorax und CT-Thorax veranlassen.
Gegebenenfalls werde ich die CT-Giografie mit Kontrast mit DERF durchführen.
Was sind Ihre Differenzialdiagnosen?
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Pneumothorax und Bronchialastma.
Was ist mit der Lunge?
Was ist mit der Herzrhythmusstörung?
Was ist mit der Röntgenstörung?
Wie könnte diese Frau behandelt werden?
Ist das möglich, noch mal eine alte Beine ohne Schwellung?